I'm very scared of heights and I like to
read romance novels I actually hate real
coasters they're way too fast and I want
to cut my finger in the tuna can and
then fainted I have five piercings two
on each ear and then one on my nose
because they like to decorate I used to
own a motorcycle and I have three here
riding tattoos one of my hobbies is
playing retro video games and I just got
a certificate in professional baking I
have two persons in my ears and they're
significant to me because my mom made
him when I was little when I was in high
school I used to go to a lot of punk
rock shows for all four years of high
school I was really into skateboarding
and fortunately never broke a bone
in high school I played Magic the
Gathering and reread the Harry Potter
books every six months I used to do
martial arts for thirteen years I'm no
third degree black belt and a nunchucks
master I once had six piercings but I
now only wear four and my piercings have
demarcated change for me I've always
been really intrigued by how like pain
solidifies a memory and so I've gotten
piercings surrounding that pain to
solidify those memories